Rick Neuheisel CBS sports college
football analyst in attendance in the
game for the game last night he joins us
Rick good morning thanks for joining us
let me start with the question that were
kind of pondering if the draft were
today and both Trevor Lawrence and
obviously Joe burrow were eligible who
would you take if you were running the
Bengals I'm taking Joe Burrell I I think
the guy - maybe the 95 mile an hour
fastball the guy is completely in
control completely dice has that ability
to kind of go back to sophomore class in
high school just dissect the opponent I
mean you remember what we did to those
frogs he's done it to defenses over and
over again
this guy is special what changed after
the first quarter for Burrell last night
well I you know Brent Venables give him
a lot of credit he was going to play
very very tight in those underneath
zones very aggressive man when they were
in zone even playing man in his own kind
of concept catch concepts down there
making it very difficult to throw the
easy throws that have been so you know
the usual for Joe burrow so they had to
go down the field and that 52 yard pass
to chase broke things open at the start
of the second half they had three cover
zero plays and two of them resulted in
sacks the other almost an ear pick and
then they went back down the field again
so once burrow and and that brain trust
on their offensive staff realized how
competitive they were going to be in
those underneath zones they started
going down the field and the rest as
they say is history we talked to you a
couple of weeks ago and you compared Joe
burrow I think more athletic Tom Brady
what kind of reaction did you get after
you said that oh I had a bunch of folks
saying to me that that's nuts that's
crazy but it's amazing how things come
around Dan you still say that I still
absolutely stand by that this guy I mean
he he has the perfect complement of
weapons he's got all the
different abilities that we look for in
terms of pocket presence the ability to
move in the pocket extend plays his
accuracy is unquestioned his
anticipation skills but he also has a
dad that's a defensive coordinator that
sits there and you know has taught him
all the tells it's as if he's always in
a poker game
that knows everybody's cards and his
ability to manipulate the secondary get
what he wants and then throw accurately
is off the charts how do you think Joe
burrows seasons gonna be remembered in
NCAA history oh it's one of the all-time
greats everybody's gonna you know wonder
who can have the Burrell effect this guy
was 16 touchdown passes and 10
interceptions a year ago he just threw
60 touchdown passes if we just took his
improvement he would have left the
country at stop that I mean it changed
though because we looked at him and he
seemed you know average last year what
changed is they a couple of things
number one Joe Brady brought in some
more formations of New Orleans Saints
formations a lot of constricted
formations where you bring the receivers
closer to the edge line they went to
five-man protection so Clyde Edwards you
layer instead of sitting there helping a
tackle was now out as an escape hatch so
they were able to save a lot of plays
Boro was thorough in terms of knowing
everything there was to know about the
offense and making sure all those pieces
around him knew everything there was the
but know about the offense and maybe
most importantly they gave him the keys
to the car he was allowed to manipulate
the protections when he saw things he
was allowed to change from run to pass
or pass to run he was given the keys to
the car and allowed to make it go and
that to me is going to be the key at the
next level this guy is really really
intelligent and if you give him some
autonomy at the line of scrimmage you're
going to be happy with the results
he's Rick Neuheisel CBS sports college
football analyst and of course former
college coach the helmet to helmet head
I there should be gray area with this it
feels like it's black or white and then
you know you're gonna send somebody out
of a national title game
you know what is intentional targeting
what is accidental targeting and should
there be a discrepancy between the two
you have hit the nail on the head we
have to go as soccer does with the red
flag and the yellow flower red card and
yellow card you have to do it because
Scouse key in this game shouldn't have
been ejected by anybody's accounts
that's just heart playing football we
all understand by letter of the law what
happened Shawn Wade in the Ohio State
Clemson game shouldn't have been ejected
those kids are playing hard they're
making good football plays certainly we
can continue to teach fundamentals and
keeping your head up but there has to be
a grade of targeting those if you need
to throw a flag if you need to you know
March off 15 yards so be it so that we
continue to teach the proper
fundamentals about keeping your eyes up
but walk those guys out of a stadium in
that kind of setting given the way they
are playing and what they meant to their
respective teams is ridiculous
more likely to be back in the national
title game next year between these two
programs Oh Clemson miles Brennan the
backup quarterback at LSU and now the
heir apparent has got some big shoes to
fill and Trevor Lawrence now tasting
defeat for the first time he was 24 25
and L going into the game last night is
going to have a great off season he'll
be motivated
they'll keep working with him you know
that was just a footwork issue last
night he was a little uncomfortable in
the pocket the ball was sailing on him
but he's got all the skills to be the
first pick a year from now why was Nick
Saban there aside from the obvious that
he got hired by ESPN but would you want
to be there if you're Nick Saban and
you're not playing in the national title
game you didn't even get into the Final
Four
it's an interesting question I listened
they asked him and I think they've got
plans for him after his coaching career
the question is how much longer does
Nick want to go the draw of that kind of
stage probably was was is the reason
while he was that why he was there but
it's a great question I don't know any
of us know exactly how long Nick Saban
wants to go but nothing motivates him
more than defeat and that a couple of
losses this year is going to rankle in
his
as they say and I think we'll see
Alabama back amongst the elite very very
soon why was he wearing blue she didn't
like the color you thought it clashed
maybe you realize I like it lady was
going to wear a very very you know
coordinated color with him so maybe he
was worth a bad angle yeah maybe I
guessed over save and being there but
when I saw him in blue and I got I
thought god I didn't know Eddie on any
other colors in there except for crimson
his sport coat designer is let's just
say not not afraid to take chances the
top 11 college football players of all
time was revealed at halftime got any
problems with this list
I really didn't obviously we have seen a
transition from the running back to the
quarterback is time marches on as you
saw their running backs counted off and
those final four and it was fun to be in
attendance and here the the ovations for
the different guys Herschel Walker
getting a monster ovation then there
they're an SEC country would you put Joe
borough in that group right now based
off of one season because I look you
know I'm gonna let it settle because
Barry Sanders is in here Barry Sanders
is in there for one season Jim Brown had
one great season I believe it's Syracuse
Herschel had a few bo Jackson had the
Heisman Trophy season
yeah I'm just curious about that that
this if you look I got running back Jim
Brown Herschel Walker running back Bo
Jackson running back Archie Griffin
running back Jim Thorpe running back Red
Grange running back Earl Campbell
running back that's the that's the top
seven players in college football
history then I go with Dick Butkus a
defensive player then another running
back then another running back Barry
Sanders Gale Sayers I got one I want Tim
Tebow I think should have been in there
and I thought he was gonna be one
believe it or not no argument from me
but as I sit there and I think
historically it's it's an it's really
kind of fascinating how the rules have
changed the game such to the fact that
now the quarterback is the key component
because obviously as we go
back in time it was the runningback that
let all things so it's just an
interesting perspective of history of
our game and I I'm with you that
quarterback should have been included as
we look back in 150 years of college
football safe travels always great to
talk to you Rick thank you all right my
friend I'm going to try to slip out of
the big OBC here okay good luck Rick
Neuheisel CBS sports college football
analyst I always learned something when
I talked to him he's a bright offensive
mind and certainly at the quarterbacking
position having played that position
when he was in college for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV streamed for free
on be our live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]